It's It's really an honor
to have the privilege to um
chat with you.
Uh I hope that we can still be friends
after this because I think I'm I'm
ready.
Okay, awesome. Well, the pleasure's
mine, my friend. Thank you for doing the
stage. So,
tell me, why do you disagree that Jesus
is God?
I disagree with a Trinitarian thing.
Mhm.
Um um my my English my might not be so
accurate and good because I am a South
African. My
um
home language is Afrikaans and I know
that [clears throat] you don't
understand Afrikaans.
How you know that?
Um do you understand Afrikaans? Uh I
don't. Yeah, I know, you might be a
prophet, man.
No, no, I'm not I'm not I'm not a
prophet.
>> [laughter]
>> But I want to start with a very
important question because I have
watched your your shows and and and I
must say that you are you are very well
equipped.
Thank you.
So, I want to ask you if a person does
not believe in the Trinity,
does that will cause him to go to hell?
Yeah, if the person is rejecting the
Trinity, like denying the Trinity, not
And so, there's a difference between
someone who doesn't necessarily
understand the Trinity and so therefore,
like, you know, they just take whatever
whatever God is and they they're they're
really agnostic on that issue, right?
But they accept the deity of Christ,
they believe in the Father, the Holy
Spirit, they don't know how that
necessarily works, they don't understand
the the Trinity.
Um that person's fine, they're ignorant,
right? But someone who is outright
denying the Trinity and rejecting the
Trinity,
then you are um you're you're you're
going against what Jesus and and the
Bible teaches. So, yeah.
Okay, so that answer will be that person
will not be saved. Yep.
>> And go to heaven. So, now my next
[clears throat] question is, what is the
requirement according to scripture
to get saved?
Yeah, so I'm going to answer this and
then hopefully we can get into why you
disagree with the Trinity, okay? But
uh yeah, so the requirement to be saved
is to believe in
Christ as who he is, as your Lord and
Savior, as your God and Savior, and that
he died for your sins and rose again on
the third day.
Okay?
Camera's need to refocus here.
Hold on. Okay. Okay. Okay. So so so so
so when
when when was that determined or
decided?
Was it Was it Was it when you came into
existence
and start to believe what you have just
said,
or was it
before the foundation of the world? Was
it
Be- Be- Be- because the the Jesus
>> Jesus has Jesus has always been
the divine Son of God from
from eternity. And so, to deny that he
is the divine Son of God,
you're not you're not going to be saved.
You're you're rejecting him. You can't
say
you believe in him and then deny who he
is. You know what I'm saying?
>> but but if a person believe in the
oneness, that the person believe in
Jesus
that he's God, but the person believe
that Jesus is the Father and Jesus is
the Holy Spirit. Yeah, no, cuz that's
that goes against what he said.
If you're if you're say No, not just the
Trinity, it's going against what Jesus
taught. Jesus taught that he's the Son,
not the Father.
So,
so you'll be calling him a liar.
You can't You have to accept Jesus for
who he is. You have to have the right
Jesus. You can't have this fake Jesus,
this flawed Jesus, going against what he
said and say that you believe in him.
But but but to understand the fullness
of Jesus' deity, does that saves you?
You don't have to know, I just said it.
You don't have to understand everything
fully. You can't deny it. You can't
reject it.
Ye- Yes, yes, but it comes it comes
according to me it comes down to that
that the the the criteria to get saved
is to know who Christ is. But according
to Ephesians 2,
uh verse 8
and 9, it was decided before the
foundation
of the world, before you were born,
you were chosen to believe in Jesus
Christ. So, my argument is, according to
Romans 10 verse 9, if you believe that
Jesus Christ died and was rose up, then
you will be saved,
irrespective if you don't believe in the
Trinity or if you or or
or you believe that Jesus is God because
if you if if you believe that Jesus is
God and he's your Savior, you will be
saved, even though you don't believe in
the Trinity.
Mhm.
Jesus says that unless you believe that
I am he, you will die in your sins.
Who is he say Who does he say he is?
He says that he's God.
Okay.
And specifically the Son, right? God the
Son. That's who he claims to be, right?
Ye- Yes, yes, yes, he is the Son of God
according to So, if you If you believe
anything else, if you don't believe that
he's the Son of God, but you believe
that he's the Father or the Spirit, you
say anything other than what Jesus said
that he is and you reject what he says,
then you do you are not you are not
holding to Romans 10:9, confessing the
Lord with your mouth and believing that
he died and rose again on the dead from
the dead. Uh you're not exercising that
Ephesians 2, where it says that you're
saved by your faith. Your faith is in in
who Jesus says he is and what he did.
Other than that,
you ain't you're off.
>> So so let me just get it clear
that even though I believe that Jesus is
God, he died
and he died for my sin according to 2
Corinthians 5 ver- uh
Yes, 2 Corinthians 5 verse 21, that that
he that knew no sin, even if I believe
that, but I'm not believing that that
God is is one in essence and three in
distinct persons, I will go to hell.
That is what you are saying to me. I'm
saying that if you are denying what
Jesus taught about himself,
then you will go to hell, which includes
that he is the distinct person from the
Father,
the divine Son of
the Son of God
as one in essence who's one in essence
with the Father, who sends the Spirit
from the Father, who is also a distinct
person from him. You deny what Jesus
teaches about himself and the Father and
who he is and what he did, you are going
>> Okay, now
Yes, now now now tell me quick. The
disciples, did they understand
the [clears throat]
who Jesus was before they were elected?
Not fully.
Exactly. But they were chosen.
So So So So, according to scripture,
you you don't get saved based on your
knowledge that you have of God. You You
You get saved because you were elected
by him. Were the Were the Were the
disciples Were the disciples saved
before
Were the disciples saved before Christ
died for their sins and stuff?
No, but they were elected to be saved.
Was Judas elected?
Excuse me? Was Judas elected?
Yes, he was selected for his role. No,
he was
He was elected the same way that all the
rest of the disciples were elected,
right? Yes, but but their roles were
different. You see, that's why Jesus say
in John 17, "No one did get lost except
the one who were predestined to get
lost." So So My point is, Reuben, is
that just because Jesus chose the
disciples doesn't mean that the
disciples were saved, as you already
know.
So, what we need to get into, my
brother, is we need to get into the the
heart of the matter. Let's get into who
Jesus is. What does the What does the
scripture say? And so then, when you we
can rest it on the correct doctrine, on
the truth of who Christ is,
and uh make sure that you
have the true gospel.
So, you believe that Christ is the
Father?
Um to be honest with you, I'm I'm I'm
not sure anymore.
You're not sure anymore? Did you Did you
at first think he was the Father, but
now you're starting to make a
distinction, or is it the
>> look look look, okay. Let me explain
this way.
The the
the
I first believed that the the Father
is not the Son and the Son is not the
Father and the Holy Spirit is not the
Son or the Father. I believe that they
were
one one God, uh three
uh uh
persons in one essence, then then I I
began to read John.
Then
um
I began to listen to Pastor Gino
Jennings.
Uh you going to begin to listen to that
heretic?
That's a That's a very strong It is.
He's a He's a heretic. He's He's a false
teacher.
It's terrible what he's doing.
And then
Now, the the here is the So, I want to
know the truth tonight. I want to
come to the conclusion because
[clears throat]
there was a time now what you are saying
to me now totally make makes me confused
because I was beginning to say to
even my children
um because I don't have the answers
anymore. As long as you believe in Jesus
Christ and he was arose according to the
Romans 10:9
then you will be saved.
But now you telling me That's why I I
ask you this question. If you don't
believe and understand the Trinity
fully, is that a salvation issue?
Yes, it is.
If you reject If you reject Sorry, not
understanding fully. If you reject and
deny
If you reject and deny the Trinity, that
is a salvation issue, not your
understanding of it. Okay?
>> So so So so so now I want to know if you
salvation Let me show you something.
Let me show you something. Let's get
right into the to heart the heart of the
matter. Okay? I want you to have the You
said you wanted to have the truth today?
Yes. Yes. Yes. So that's what we're
going to do. We're going to get into the
scriptures and we're going to get right
to the meat of the matter so we don't
have to
we don't have to you know, kind of
play around with confusions. Make sense?
All right. So let me let me share my
screen so that you can
also see.
Okay.
It's not too not too big, right? Or not
too small? You can see the screen?
Um let me just make it bigger. Yes. Yes,
I can see. All right. I'll make it
bigger too on my end.
All right. There we go. That should be a
little better.
All right. So it says
it says "Yet even if I judge if I do
judge
my judgment is true." This is Jesus
speaking, obviously. "For it is not I
alone who judge
but I and the Father who sent me."
It's paused here.
So Jesus gives a reason for why his
judgment would be true if it was him
judging.
Right? "If I judge, my judgment is
true." He says why right here.
"For it is not I alone who judge
but I and the Father
who sent me."
So according to Jesus, if he was
judging, how many would be judging?
Two.
Exactly. Two.
One is himself
and the other is the Father, right?
What What What What What What passage is
this? This is John chapter 8 verses 16.
John We're going to
We're going to read verse 16 to 18.
John chapter 8 verse 16.
Mhm.
>> [sighs]
>> Okay. But even if I do judge, my
judgment is true for I am not alone in
it. Yes. Yes. Yes.
All right. So he's He's very clear.
"It's not I alone." To be alone means to
be by yourself, right?
Like nobody else is with you. But he
says, "I'm not alone. It's not I alone
who judge but I
and meaning in addition and the Father
who sent me." So there's two
who judge.
So this would mean that Jesus
cannot be the Father. If Jesus was the
Father
that would make this verse a lie because
it would be Jesus alone judging.
But he says, "I'm not alone judging.
There's another with me that's judging
along with me. It's myself and my Father
together we judging."
Like goes on and makes it clear. Watch
this. Verse 17.
"In your law it is written
that the testimony of two people is
true."
He's He's You already You already You
already caught it up.
"The testimony of two people is true."
This is according to the Torah, he says.
Now watch what he says. Who are the two
people
who have who are bearing witness? Who is
Who has their testimony?
"I am the one
who bears witness about myself
and the Father who sent me bears witness
about me."
So according to Jesus, who are the two
witnesses
that are bearing witness?
Yes.
So
I I I I just need to deal with that
quickly. So
>> [laughter]
>> It's okay.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. You see it? [snorts]
John
So there's no possible way that Jesus
and the Father are the same person or
else Jesus' testimony is not even valid
according to the law.
He's bearing witness about it by
himself.
>> [snorts]
>> Can I just call my wife quick? Baby, go
go go go find someone.
>> [laughter]
>> What what do you want? Can Can we hear?
Be Be because this is now a debate that
goes on for years in our house. Mhm. And
I want to ask you
um if I can organize a meeting with my
son-in-law and my daughter because I am
afraid for them now.
Yeah. Of course.
Because I need to rectify now because I
am the pastor of the of the church and
there was a time I even did let me be
baptized over according to
>> [snorts]
>> uh Acts 2:38 because someone told me if
you're not
baptized in the name of Jesus Mhm. um
then you're not going to be saved. So
um to be honest with you, um you bring
so much clarity now. John John Why
didn't I see John 8?
Sometimes we read, brother, and it just
it it goes right over our head
sometimes. We you know, sometimes we
miss it. That's how
But the word of the Lord is alive, isn't
it? And so when we see it and it clicks
so much clarity and it's like
it's it's a relief.
You know? Is Is there Is there any other
proof
except this? Oh, absolutely. So there's
a bunch.
Um if if you're going besides the verses
where Jesus is being baptized in the in
the Holy Spirit descends on Jesus and
then the Father speaks from heaven and
says, "This is my son in whom I'm well
pleased." You know, he does that
multiple times on the mountain of
transfiguration, the Father
orders the disciples, "Hey, this is my
son. Listen to him." Right? So there's
there's a distinction. He's pointing to
someone else. The Father's pointing to
someone else. "This is who I love."
Right? To To
To have a beloved means that there is a
relationship, right?
And relationship takes at least two.
A relationship to a beloved is a is at
least between one party and another
party.
Well, the Father says that Jesus is his
beloved son. So that's their
relationship. So they can't be the same
person.
That's the relationship that he has with
the son.
Here's another one, though.
Here's another one.
Uh let's go to We'll be in John. Let's
do
John
15:26.
>> Because I I I'm not just doing this for
me now. I I'm doing this for my
for my son-in-law for my family because
my my my daughter even sees at
Stellenbosch University. I don't know if
you ever have heard of that university.
It is one of the best
universities in South Africa. She's busy
studying theology. I'm also studying
theology. I'm in my second year now.
And the confusion just
arise, [clears throat] man, because
I am a seeker of the truth and I truly
want to know the truth. Amen. That's
good.
Yeah, I got you. Um
And like And again, this is recorded on
YouTube. So like you you guys can play
this back and go through these.
Um and if you want, we can also probably
hop on a We could probably schedule
something and I can talk to your family
members if you want if they're open to
that.
Yes, they will definitely be open
because me and my son-in-law, we had a
debate over this tonight. Oh, yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> And and somehow
yeah, all of a sudden I just came up
because I I did subscribe to your
channel and here's here's this topic. So
I thought now I'm going to wait until
10:11 to to in South African time 10
past 11 until you [clears throat] get
up.
Yeah.
>> [snorts]
>> Well, I'm here for you, brother. I thank
you for waiting and coming up. You know,
God ordained this.
So, look. So, this is John chapter 15,
verse 26, okay? Watch the distinctions
that Jesus makes here. John chapter 15,
verse 26. It's so so good, so clear,
very powerful. Watch what Jesus says. He
says,
"But when the Helper comes,
Now, the Helper is the Holy Spirit,
right? Jesus is talking about when he
goes to the Father, he's going to send
the Holy Spirit, okay? That's the
Paraclete. Exactly.
"But when the Helper comes,
whom I will send to you." So, Jesus is
the one sending the Holy Spirit.
So, he can't be the Holy Spirit himself.
He's There's a distinction. He's sending
the Holy Spirit, so there's a
distinction, right? Now, watch this.
"whom I will send to you
from the Father."
So, the the Holy Spirit is from the
Father. He's not the Father, he's from
the Father.
Right? Yes. So, there's a We already see
a distinction between the three. Jesus,
the Son, sends the Holy Spirit, who is
from the Father.
Father, Son, Holy Spirit, three distinct
persons.
Still working in perfect unison
together. Watch this. So,
"But when the Helper comes, whom I will
send to you
from the Father, the Spirit of truth,
who proceeds from the Father."
Meaning he comes out of the Father.
The Father doesn't come out of himself,
it's the Spirit who comes out of the
Father. There's a distinction there.
He proceeds from the Father.
And then watch what he says. "He will
bear witness about me." There's another
witness.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, you have the the Father bears
witness about the Son.
The Son bears witness about himself,
that's two.
And the Spirit bears witness about the
Son, that's three. There's three that
bear witness about the Son. The Father,
the Son, and the Spirit together.
Three three distinct persons, three
distinct witnesses, which also
vindicates Jesus' testimony according to
the law.
Yes.
Make sense? Yes, it makes it makes
perfect sense. I I
But the the the thing is now, the answer
to that what I always hear
and and and and what I want you to make
clear to me is that
was was the body
of Jesus, the Son, but the Spirit was
God.
Yeah, no. So, yeah, that's a
a slight misconception. So, it's not
just simply that the body is the Son.
Christ, the person, Christ
[clears throat] the person, the Word,
right? Before he even takes on flesh, is
known as the Son. He That's who he is.
He's always been the Son of the Father.
Let me just show you this really quick.
For example, you have Hebrews chapter
1.
Hebrews chapter 1.
Let me just pull up the whole thing.
Watch this.
"Long ago, at many times and in many
ways, God spoke to our fathers by the
prophets.
But in these last days, he has spoken to
us by his Son,
whom he appointed the heir of all
things,
through whom, through the Son,
also he created the world."
So, even before the world was created,
Jesus was the Son.
Yes.
Amen.
So, he's eternally the Son, and let me
tell you why. This should make sense as
well. The reason why Jesus is eternally
the Son
is because God is
unchanging. God doesn't change, right?
And so, the Father didn't become the
Father. He's always been the Father.
He's eternally been the Father.
Well, in order to eternally be the
Father, he has to eternally have the
Son, right?
If God is always the Father, then God
always has the Son.
If the Son is always the Son, then he
always has the Father.
But what about John 4:24, the Spirit?
The [snorts and clears throat] the And
I'm And I'm And I'm And I'm asking this
question not to put up a argument. I
just want clarity because
>> No, cuz these are these are usually
things that they bring up. They'll bring
up John 4:24.
They'll bring up a few things. Jesus
Jesus saying things he's in the Father.
>> God is Spirit.
So, so so so the the Spirit of God, and
I know the Old Testament talk about the
Ruach of God of
of God. Sorry, I I'm speaking Afrikaans
now. The Ruach of of God.
So,
the Holy Spirit,
is it not the Father?
Mhm.
>> [clears throat]
>> Nope.
And so, since since we have that clear,
like it's it's it's When when we have
this clarity, now we can look at these
passages with more clarity, right? So,
for example, we we already have
established the Holy Spirit is distinct
from the Father. He comes from the
Father, right? So, now
Exactly.
>> [clears throat]
>> Mhm.
So, now when we look at this then, okay,
what it says that for God is Spirit,
and the Father is looking for those to
worship him in spirit and in truth,
right? So, obviously he's speaking about
the Father in particular,
but that he is he is Spirit. So, it's
really talking about the ontology and
the nature of the Father, that he is
Spirit. He's not a physical being, he's,
you know, he's spiritual. He's a He He
is Spirit. He's the source of Spirit.
Right? He's the source of the spiritual.
So, as opposed to all these people who
may think that they are Like in this
context, Jesus tells them, "You worship
what you do not know.
We though, we worship what we know."
So, even though this Like they're
they're worshiping, they're not they're
not in the truth yet. They're not in the
truth even though they
would deem themselves to be spiritual.
But no, the God is Spirit. And the
Father is looking for those to worship
him in spirit and in truth, meaning they
have to be in the truth,
one with him, and that clarity and that
truth comes from the Son through the
Spirit.
Okay? So, it's talking about the
ontology of the Father, that he is
Spirit. God is Spirit by nature.
Not that he's the person of the Holy
Spirit.
Does it make sense?
Yeah, it it it
As as I understand it now,
I hope my English is clear, but as I
understand it is that
um as you explain it to me now, spirit
and truth, so the word is the truth. So,
the only way we can serve God is through
the Holy Spirit that enables us to obey
the the truth. Boom boom.
You got it.
It's the Holy Spirit. Look, even the
scripture says, it says that it's by the
Holy Spirit that we confess that Christ
is Lord. It's by the Holy Spirit. He's
the one who convicts us that Christ is
Lord of his death and burial and
resurrection.
But but but but
one more question that I actually had
ready to to put up a argument with you,
and I want you to clear that up for me
also, is that according to Ephesians,
um that our salvation is by grace
through faith.
Yeah. So,
if that is the case,
where does understanding come in
in order [clears throat] for us to be
saved? That's why I ask you in the
beginning. Yeah. What is the criteria to
get saved? Because if that is the
the the the the the the the scenario
that we are saved by grace, which means
freely, we didn't deserve it, we didn't
do anything to to get it,
um so, that is what I couldn't
understand why is it that a person that
will that actually believe that Jesus is
the Father and and Jesus is the Holy
Spirit will not inherit the kingdom.
Well, it's So, it's what is your faith
in?
Right? It's not just simply, "Oh, just
having faith." No, what what is it What
is the faith that saves?
So, that That means that there is a true
faith
that saves, right? Salvation comes
through a true faith.
So, you can't have Like Like So, for
example, if um
let's say I'm I'm saying that I believe
that Jesus [clears throat] died for my
sins and rose again on the third day,
but but according to what I what I mean
by that is I believe that Jesus is a
created Archangel of of Jehovah,
a creature who came
>> I know that's that's not biblical.
>> Exactly. You You see what I'm saying?
It's not biblical. And that's my point,
is that when you put this type of faith
would be a false faith, an unbiblical
false faith, even though you're making
the claim that you believe that Jesus
died for your sins. You have to have You
have to believe
in who Jesus is. That's the faith that
you're putting in. Now, when it comes to
the complexities of And And you have you
have to believe what he commanded. You
got to believe
like you can't I can't say that I have
faith in Jesus. I have faith he's he's
the Lord of my life who died for my sins
and resurrected and reject what he
taught at the same time, right? That
would be a false faith. So if I come to
if I come to knowledge and say and like
Jesus died for my sins, he rose again,
he's a he's a divine son of God, right?
He's the son of God. This is what I
believe. He died for my sins, rose
again. I'm saved through his work, not
my work. I'm saved through his work.
But I don't fully understand
him coming in the flesh. Like how how
does that work? I don't I don't fully it
doesn't I don't fully comprehend that or
what what really is the distinction
between him and the Father if there is
one. I I don't really understand how
that works. However,
I'm standing on Jesus is the son of God.
God is the Father, the have our heavenly
Father and the Holy Spirit that they
send. I'm a stand I don't know exactly
how that works.
I don't understand it fully the
distinctions if there are any
distinctions whatever. I don't
understand it, but I'm just accepting
what the scripture is saying.
I'm not going to reject this. I'm not
going to deny this.
That is different from someone who's
claiming to have a faith
and in knowledge sees what Jesus is
saying that the Father bears witness,
the Holy Spirit bears witness and then
did not but denying that. Rejecting what
Jesus says and making up their own
doctrine that Jesus is the Father. He is
the Holy Spirit despite what he says.
That person is different from someone
who doesn't quite fully understand.
Yeah, so it come it it comes now to me
and this is the
the the the the the concern now over my
children is that the argument always
goes and I I want you also to give me
clarity on this.
If we get into heaven,
are we going to see three gods?
Which which which which I answer them
no. We going to see Jesus Christ
according to scripture. Yeah.
Um so to be honest with you, um in the
in the
past four years, this is a debate and
and actually there came a time like even
tonight that I actually had decided,
okay,
I don't have a answer for this. I can't
convince them.
Um and I don't want to say that that
they are going to hell because they
don't believe in the in the triune God
as as as I
want to believe and and and be certain,
but to
due to debates and stuff like that, I I
acknowledge Jesus is God. He's the son
of man. [clears throat] He's the son of
God. But this question stands like a
hole
in the water that if you don't
acknowledge the triune God, will you go
to hell? So to to tonight you actually
answered that.
So I am even more I'm I'm I'm happy for
for for myself. I I got more convinced
and I have clarity, but now I'm even
more worried about them.
Well, there here we do we have an
opportunity to talk with your family
members and you know, prayerfully
they'll they're as humble as you are and
open to the truth as you are, you know.
Um and
and they accept what the Bible says.
That's that's all we're going to do is
talk Bible. If they
they accept scripture, they accept the
words of Jesus and what he taught, they
accept the guidance of the Holy Spirit,
we should be good, you know? So let's
pray that that that we can connect and
get a conversation with them and
they'll be humbly open to the
scriptures, to correction.
Amen. Yes. Yeah, so nothing to worry
about. Just pray. Pray about it. God is
in control of this
and God will will be done.
Just one more question before I go
>> You keep saying that. It's like you're
it's like you're
it's your 10th one more question.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, one sorry sorry my brother. Thank
you very much for for the clarity.
There's one one very very important
question. Sure.
My son-in-law and my daughter,
if they decide on a date and a time or
whenever you tell them,
would you be able to to speak in front
of more people or or or or or what?
Because [snorts] I want my daughter in
Stellenbosch, she also believe fully in
this oneness and and I and I'm trying to
convince them. So I I I actually want
more people in we can put you on the big
screen so that you can just go through
with them with all these passages and
allow them to to have a Q&A with you
because I'm really concerned now. Yeah.
Yeah, we can set that up.
They can they can
they'll be able to join the stream like
this, like how you did. You guys can put
me on the TV or the big screen so
everybody can watch and
yeah, we can we can do it just like
this.
We'll set it up.
Thank you, brother. I am convinced and I
confess that my God is
one in essence and three in distinct
person. He is a triune God. Amen.
Hallelujah. Thank you, brother. Of
course.
>> [laughter]
>> How do I go
off now and I want to tell you
in Afrikaans so that you must start you
must begin Afrikaans learn them to talk
so that you buy a mere men so fancy
Africa up your so can hit. What does it
what that means it say? You must learn
to speak Afrikaans so that you can have
more South African people on the show.
Amen. For sure.
>> [laughter]
>> God bless you, Ruben. So nice to meet
you, brother. I got you.
>> Bye-bye. God bless you. Thank you. Okay.
What a way to start off the stream.
Glory to God.
What a way to start to start off the
stream.
Wow.
A father who's just seeking, who's open
to the scriptures, honest with the
scriptures,
letting the scriptures speak and letting
the Holy Spirit guide his and convict
his heart.
That that simple, guys.
It's really that simple. When someone
loves the Lord, they will adhere to his
voice and they'll hear his word and they
will submit to his correction without
question.
When someone loves the Lord. Some of us,
you know, are a little more hard-headed.
Some of us some a little bit more
hard-headed and that's okay. Some of us
got to look got to kick a little bit and
scream a little bit, but you know,
God will pull us into that room. But
man, when someone has a genuine heart
for the Lord,
they love his word, they adhere to his
voice,
it's it's a smooth it's a smooth
transition.
Clarity hits, correction.
That's that's our God. And notice this,
guys. Did you guys did you guys see?
Our God does not mind your doubts.
I'll say that again.
The true God is not afraid of your
doubts.
Bring them to him.
Bring him your doubts. Bring him your
questions. Bring him your burdens. Lay
it on him and he will bring you clarity
and give you rest. Do you see how the
the relief on brother Ruben's face?
Y'all see the relief?
How happy he was?
Having clarity and and and in the truth
of who God is?
That's literally Matthew 11.
Come to me and I will give you rest for
your souls.